that we just got back from a uh
meeting not a meeting what is an
engagement
with one of the bigger tech people here
in austin yeah
and uh it was a lot of fun we've got
whitney webb later on on the show
uh talking about some things coming down
the
pike with the vaccine passport
and um we met this dude through a mutual
guide he was a nice
guy brilliant guy very smart very
successful um
when we walked in he felt i felt like he
didn't really know us or knew who we
were what we did
um i think he only has a slightly better
understanding of it after the two hours
but we played pickleball which is a
game it's like uh it's a cross between
tennis and
ping pong and it's very interesting when
you meet like
high-powered successful people a lot of
times they're like do something athletic
in front of me let's see if you can do
something
uh do you have a competitive edge do you
want to win you know it was like that
kind of
they said there was going to be a lunch
we walked in there was like hummus and a
strawberry so it was like not exactly
but that's fine they're healthy that's
what they eat you know what i mean tech
successful
it was a scene from ex machina is what
it was but it was lovely it was lovely
and um
you know the house is you know
tremendous and beautiful and uh and then
they go let's play some pickleball you
guys play pickleball and i was like i
don't really know what it is but i'm
sure
um i will do it and then um it's a cross
between
tennis and ping pong so you have it's
like a court
in a gym and you're playing uh
pickleball and um
me and ben of course are gonna play
together but then they said well you're
both beginners so you should play with
the other people there so we did and
it was now you look at me and you look
at ben and you're like oh ben
he's gonna be the athlete ben was so bad
at this game
and he kept cheating by going into this
area where you were not supposed to go
into
um it was so embarrassing
now they're in gym clothes me and ben of
jeans on because we didn't really know
it was raining we didn't know it was
gonna happen and um
i was doing pretty damn good like a few
of the other people there were like
you're gonna be really good at this i
had a great you know because i
i played tennis as a kid a little bit
and i i know how to really just kind of
hit the ball just have it sail right
over the net ben was aggressively
you know we're playing doubles and ben
was aggressively trying to
like hit the ball in front of the other
people and then just
failing miserably at it did you know how
bad you were doing
i charged the net a couple of times it
was embarrassing did you feel
how how bad you were doing i had a
couple
were you shocked who told you that
well i can't say his name but he he was
not
i was doing very well you were great at
serving
very good you know what you know what
see this is what he's trying to do
i was doing really really well okay
i do what i do well and ben likes to
pretend he does everything well
i was i'm an amazing server and then i
could also do the volley but i also feel
like after i've done the serve
i should be done for the point i don't
want to run around the court like a
psychopath it's unbecoming of a man of
my stature
so i do the serve and then the other
person runs around like a monkey
and then i was good at returning too
he's being a piece of [ __ ]
because he was he was genuinely
embarrassing and there's a boat these
are
really rich successful people judging us
and the pig is murdering it running
around the court doing what i have to do
uh and then this guy's uh family walked
in and then they were all staring there
watching ben just
wildly run around and it was so
it was hard to see it was hard to see
for me because i felt bad for ben i was
embarrassed for ben
we'd never done anything athletic before
and you
you thought you were thinking that i was
just gonna not be good at all
that's not true at all that's what you
felt no i know but what happened
yes pipe down what happened was
i was phenomenal i was pretty damn good
the guy looked at me and said you are
going to be very good at this
the other guy the main guy said you were
good when did he say that
he actually said twice he was like wow
that was really impressive when i was up
there like i had a couple of times where
it was
that's one isolated thing that's not a
review of your performance for the
entire
day it's what you did one or two good
things i don't think i missed a serve
though
like i didn't i didn't had to serve out
of bounds though i had the services
i was just saying between me and you
would you argue that i did a little
better
uh oh wow overall yeah overall you won
more games
well that would be that's they care
about winning
you understand what metric are you
deciding i won more games what metric
are you going off of
um inner belief
well anyway
after the game uh we hung out and ate uh
hummus and it was nice it's a matcha
it's delicious yeah so matcha it was uh
uh lovely meeting new people here in uh
austin texas and um
you know we're not influenced by anyone
ever on this show we're never influenced
i've nev i've never in like i am never
influenced
by anyone on this show like i like i
meet successful powerful people all the
time
but i'm never like a guy who's like oh i
should
start evangelizing on the behalf of
anyone
i've never felt that i've never felt
that you know what i mean yeah
i i do and this is unrelated this is
an unrelated point i was thinking this
morning
about what a great company palantir is
while i had my eggs
and i just i woke up and i said what a
great
company it is because they have all the
information
of the people and that's what you want
you want you want all the information
to be in a place and i think that's
they do it good they do it well
so i'm a fan of them yeah great
investment
it's a great investment yeah i also
would like to say
i like the central intelligence agency
i like them they're efficient
they're mysterious
and i think that we have to relax when
we are um
always with the bringing up the bad
things they did in the past
enough with that stop that
there everyone's made mistakes when i
was young i kicked my friend i wasn't
becoming my character that's not who i
am
so i like the central intelligence age i
like
it and i think it's good
and i don't think you should
be upset if people want to listen
to what you're saying on the phone
or read your email i don't
think that's a problem i don't think
it's a big deal
i don't think it's a big deal if people
know what medications you're on
and if they need to be refilled i
i i'm okay with that and you should be
too i think we asked too many questions
do you understand i understand what
you're saying and i'm just saying
i'm an independent broadcaster
who has thoughts that are in his head
that he says them they are not given to
me by anyone
and they are i am not influenced by
anyone
but god damn it if jeff bezos isn't a
great [ __ ] guy
he's a great guy and i
i want things to be delivered to me and
with a drone
right yes
so that's what i'm saying i'm saying
those things and only those things
mark zuckerberg gets a bad rap
he's a sweet boy who's created a thing
that's a little wacky
do you understand
jack dorsey is a fine man he's a fine
man he's created a platform that makes
me feel better about the world and our
ability to
have a meaningful dialogue i love you
jack
do you understand whoever owns
page i love them the patreon uh people
you are good p hey eric schmidt at
google
these are i i'm just saying
that i l i love people in tech
i like them i think it's important that
we get off their back
get off their back i like that
they don't have an expression all the
time on their face i like that
i think that's nice how many people do
you meet where they have a
when you look at them they have an
expression and they go hello or and you
see
oh you're happy or you're sad or you're
embarrassed i like when there is none
i think it's refreshing i think it's
modern
i think it's modern i think it's very
modern
when someone looks at you and does it
you can't quite tell if they are
if they're real i like that i
i enjoy that that's what i like
you don't the people are so caught up in
like
oh i should be able to say what i want i
don't think so
i don't think so i believe
that you should get a list of words that
you can say
which will be shorter than the ones that
you cannot and that will make it easier
for you
i i'm just saying i am saying that i'm
i am not i have not been co-opted at all
okay at all i'm just
saying
that i'm
i want to get the vaccine
more than twice
i'd like to get it six or seven times
is what i'm saying do you understand and
a lot of people are like
oh oh you're in texas and you're meeting
all these uh
people and you're you're they're
influencing you no
no that's not it i'm realizing
how lucky i am that there is an industry
taking care of me
taking care of us all they're taking
care of us
all thank the lord
i like it i like people pooping in the
street
i don't think it's a big deal i think if
if you think it's a big deal you should
start a company and buy a house
out of the city but i think
people should be able to poop in the
street
sorry i'm a humanitarian
okay so i wanted to get that out of the
way because people are always
nervous how and and when we'll be
co-opted
so there's not i just want to let people
know there is no fear of that at all
no fear of that at all okay let's do an
ad break here we do we do have an ad
hold on hold on let's get it
let's get the ad here
the tim dylan show is proud to be
sponsored by the national security
agency
the national security agency we're
watching out for you
here at the nsa we are pioneering new
ways to make
americans safe that is our top priority
keeping you safe by using many different
ways to get information
it's not really important how we get the
information it's important
we do with it what we think is best the
national security agency
we're the we love you
all right that was our first ad break
let's do a second ad break because we
roll in two
moderna as now sponsoring the tim dillon
show
moderna has developed a vaccine it is
fun and it is two shots you will love it
and enjoy it
and afterwards it will be
shown that you have taken it in a wallet
so you can get into basketball games
and concerts moderna is always working
hard
to try to solve the problems of tomorrow
all right just have to get these added
out of the way folks
it's just the tim dylan show is proud to
be sponsored by the bill and melinda
gates foundation
bill and melinda are here to help they
want you to know that
bill has spent years tirelessly trying
to solve every problem that has ever
arisen
from climate change to vaccines
and diseases and overpopulation
and how these all go together somehow
bill and melinda are very excited
to help people through their charitable
donations and
foundations and contributions
on this show i have said things about
bill that are not true
because i am a stupid pig don't listen
to the stupid pig
do your own research at
their website the bill and melinda gates
foundation because that is where the
accurate information is
all other sources are not to be trusted
i am sorry for what i have said about
bill and melinda gates it was
inappropriate and down right wrong
i wrestle with the guilt of what i have
said about them
sometimes it is so bad that i lay in bed
all day like i have just taken the
much-needed second shot
of the moderna vaccine this ad copy's
good it's not bad
i am very very happy i love bill and
everything he has done for the third
world
and our world let's and all of the
worlds
bill and melinda gates i am very sorry
that i said that warren buffett was a
creepy old goblin
and that him and bill were frauds and
that
they have a plan that if only we had any
clue about it it would
scare us all i apologize for that
i also apologize for continually
bringing up the epstein
angle with bill because bill had no idea
what jeffrey was doing
i'm a fat opportunist who likes to link
people's
is a long head who likes to link people
together that had nothing to do with
each other
it is because i am fat and i am not
thinking clearly that i have
constantly brought up previous
associations with uh jeffrey epstein
i am sorry i want to take this
opportunity to apologize to
bill melinda and warren buffett for all
of my transgressions
and i am excited to welcoming them as
sponsors of my new show
where i will be vaccinated on the table
in front of everyone
so i think it's important that people
know and trust us you know what i mean
and that's
because there's so many people out there
right now in the entertainment business
that are
you know people don't trust them but i
feel like
we have to kind of show everybody that
just because we're in austin and just
because we know some of these people
we have not changed who we are like our
core beliefs and values which have
always been a deep love of the
intelligence community
and and big pharma why are
you know are you do you people realize
how lucky you are
with the pharmaceuticals that
you can get them when you are young and
keep taking them for your entire life
do you realize how lucky you are many
people don't have the chance
to begin a regimen of adderall at three
and then take uh puberty blocking
hormones
at nine and then graduate to
lithium at twelve and then
keep going on a cocktail of different
medications
until uh you're in a grave it is so
nice i just want to throw that out there
i just want to throw that out there
because i think i've been very
hard on the pharmaceutical industry um
i've said that they're selling us junk
cures for products like you know for
problems that they've invented
and i want to say that i'm dead wrong i
am dead
think of this everything i have said
before today i have been dead wrong
dead wrong and
i realized that i i have realized that
i've been dead wrong i think chelsea
handler's doing a good job
with her documentaries about uh black
people
i want more of them i want
more of her content
i i believe in her
and her mission
and if i've ever said anything on this
show that makes people doubt that
it's because i'm uh a bad
person but i'm trying to get better at
that
do you understand yes i do
do you understand now since we left this
person's house my cell phone has not
worked
and i don't i think that's a coincidence
right yeah probably there's something
odd with my car
when i turn it on it makes a weird sound
but i don't think that any of that
is related
do you think we'll be invited back i
hope so they were lovely they were very
fun i had a great time
what are the chances i think fifty
percent
okay okay
what do you think um i don't know
i'll get better at pickleball in the
meantime but i hope so
i just want to use this opportunity
why are you why are you i'm not i'm not
i want to use this opportunity
to talk about
my love
my love for
elizabeth holmes
she made one mistake you know
one mistake that's all
you know
why are you all you're all nervous now
i'm not nervous at all
why are you all nervous i'm not nervous
you're very nervous you think they're
gonna kill you
you think they'd kill you you think
they'd waste their time
remotely hijacking your tesla
when you and your wife are going to get
oysters
at whatever dump is in austin
you think they'd waste their time
killing
you are you have you not
lost your mind
if they're going to kill anyone it's
going to be me
i don't want anyone to kill you
that's true would not be good
but i was i was i did all the ads and i
was supposed to do
so i don't think we're going to have an
issue
do you think so i enjoyed it and i hope
we're invited again i love our new
sponsors i love our new friends
i and i was wrong to
question why bill gates wanted to shoot
a missile of dust at the sun
that was a mistake i'm sorry about that
i think he i think he should shoot a
missile of whatever he wants
at whatever he wants
i don't you understand that i want my
audience to know
that i have integrity okay